foreign
i'm not gonna lie it's always a rush
getting access to these clandestine
worlds
the cocaine pit the starting point for
such a storied black market trade
ranks up there but as the reporter high
wears off
i realize that the whole process boils
down to brute labor
and simple chemistry
[Music]
so they've been doing this for three
days and now this is the final step
which they mix it with salt
it takes 400 kilos almost 900 pounds
of cocoa leaves to make one kilo of
cocaine
they're soaked in water acid and bleach
which draws the drugs
out of the leaves and now it's ready to
be moved on to smaller containers
to the lab in the aquiba laboratory
[Music]
here in this makeshift lab they'll start
the purification process
[Music]
researchers discovered how to extract
cocaine from coca leaves
over 150 years ago and americans got
their first taste of the drug
in coca-cola back in the 19th century
before it was banned by the federal
government in 1914
it's a really really intense smell
to purify cocaine in the middle of the
peruvian jungle
they figured out how to extract the drug
using simple household chemicals
and a whole lot of gasoline in this lab
each batch requires 70 gallons
ammonia bleach cement
lime gasoline with each toxic additive
the drug becomes more and more
concentrated
what they're doing is that they're
removing the top of it which is the fuel
and the bottom is a clear sort of liquid
and that's where the drugs remain
you see it's pretty dark and that's all
the gasoline
and the clear part now underneath yes
okay
so yeah that's the drugs right there
so they call that clear liquid they call
it the soup
[Music]
[Laughter]
no
it's crazy to think that only weeks from
now this jungle soup will disappear
up some americans nostrils
now it's time for the final step a
splash of ammonia
to solidify the drugs
[Music]
okay they have to speed it we have to
speed it up guys with
so many livelihoods depending on this
slab ceviche's friend is taking a
massive risk
giving us a peek behind the curtain so
when the chemist disappears for a moment
i begin
[Music]
we have to go right now
[Music]
let's go let's go i guess we were
spotted
by somebody
are they all inside
thankfully we escape without incident
but the drugs long journey north
is only just beginning
[Music]
you